yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing ender from the Netherlands
insulting and not one of my favourite
openings to play against okay Alice's
this is this is nicer like definitely
should go for c5 based play here then we
can still play c5 now hmm
[Music]
No
so um can I win a pawn here bishops e75
yeah it does win a pawn okay
it's not it's not very desirable to take
there to be honest even though it winds
upon takes takes on d5 95 yeah now I
don't like it edges to anti positional
to give up that Bishop for that
completely misplaced 9 ok so I can even
be three comes in to consumer not yeah
just keep the tension
[Music]
still one day where this night is going
okay now I think I'm reasonably well
positioned to play this baby night a
6-foot level team now you want to play
494
do you find I'm surprised about and
don't quite believe that this helped so
much have an easy play this and act a
groupie seven looks very difficult for
black even be six is a move
95 is a double attack
f 7 and C 6 so I mean I think you have
to take it that doesn't look right
rook d7 I also have Bishop g4 and and
things like that yeah this is actually a
good move if you move the rook I can
take and play Bishop d7 double attacking
c6 98 we have X position is extremely
loose
[Music]
I just have to check out bishop doesn't
have all that many squares on c6 but he
has a hard time to check it
Queen 2 is 6 maybe I can go to the 7
doesn't really feel dangerous
umm-hmm
still not clear how I'm doing a gem
maybe here taking me five what does he
want to go no I was just thinking maybe
g-forces idea
[Music]
show him if he moves the night I was
thinking c6 but this was kind of a
debatable decision for sure my bishop
looks a bit strange they saw a b7
[Music]
don't like this so much it looks a bit
bit weird
you
may
some sneezes here ah yeah
boom now I was thinking I wanted to UM
okay
then I wanted to play this completely
differently in fact okay so here I am I
have to really watch out yeah h4 is
going to play and I was going to play g3
it what can I do
time warning maybe yet should be two or
something and my bishop is attacked
oh my good oh my goodness just have this
which was not planned they'd still be
should be too yeah I completely lost
control of this possession and it was
complete control at one point like 459 I
was bad yeah
okay I should just I should just take
him I mean
okay let's have a look down yeah here I
can win the pawn but I didn't want to it
just looks wrong like this this was a
way to work on but I didn't like it yeah
I mean somehow black get some activity
it's from the northern office and and
suggest but I still didn't want to give
him that that freedom down and tell us
making steady steady progress sound very
nice
can actually argue about about this 95
move maybe hope this heaven also looks
very strong so where I want this and now
I still got into trouble yeah maybe this
wasn't good
I had this F 3 e 4 idea but a little bit
later I think it's a really good one
because I'm breaking up the whole Center
and then make sure that the bishop does
stuff he I didn't see this as a point at
the engine sees but even this is good I
think
yeah I'm opening up this and everything
kind of works together nicely yeah in
the game I really am allowed far too
much this is not great iam yeah I should
just click and now I can I have have a
bit of time to consolidate this it's not
ideal especially not in the bits game
and with this Bishop being of offside
yeah this is now really got dangerous
twin GA twins and they I was so
completely losing control them so I
should go P should be one and I'll have
to take all uses 7 1896 was good
we should be twerking so sacrifice the
exchange between everyone is what I have
to do and here things are kind of okay
again that he lost everything
yeah that was a murky end to this game
okay guys thanks for watching